yeah what a big mood people we are here
we are clearly here
nailed it nice nice like where she's
going where she going what's going in
there she is she's in the same spot a
little bit of a spinoff of last week's
episode because we're also ovulating
Rosa yeah we're all still horny we all
still ain't got that dick we need to we
need to talk about it because I feel
like I'm just now as some of you know
Gio was very surprised to learn that I
had just figured out what ovulation was
although it's so funny yeah and uh all
surprise girls whoa I didn't know
shocked I know I need to talk through
these feelings yeah because how you
supposed to know exactly and then
there's other people out there that
don't know - and like weird it's like
we're all horny this week we're all the
same cycle dude we are all synched up we
are naptime I'm a week off I think from
everyone no yeah you gotta sing cuz I
just ended my period but I'm still
literally obviating tomorrow is I just
finished up always yeah it doesn't
matter i I don't talk about sex baby
let's talk about you that was the
episode we did like two weeks ago all
right well we're still talking about sex
are shoe or knee this is what you guys
want we see the numbers oh you talk
about real [ __ ] y'all don't show what we
talk about [ __ ] you'll show up horny
so that's what we're doing you're just
as we are yes right now bullied us into
talking so I was thinking about this
before we even rolled into the episode
and I'm just like okay is there some
kind of trigger is there something they
see I think that there's like a common
misconception that like we as women like
yes we like abs but do we see abs and it
like immediately the factory just starts
producing like number can't like
absolutely not
there has to be like a thing men are
more visual traditionally and like
moreover across the board more visual so
they can get turned on by seeing a
picture of titties whereas women are
more
visceral they like a breath just
triggered something your mind would be
she turn you on no it made me realize
I'm in a more visual right we send a
picture of our breasts and they're like
great I am horny is this why they send a
day pic yeah because they're like great
she's gonna let me reciprocate okay
let's talk about that we don't get
turned on by that
you're already into the guy though right
yeah it can't necessarily wind up like
Iran like gel actually the porn I watch
I've got to be honest I watch guys
masturbating no I love that too but it
shows go into that but I did choose it
so when you're but it's visual dick pics
no no like a guy could just get a random
tittie pic and be like oh I'm turned on
yeah yeah I know I don't get turned on
if it's just out of the blue yeah but I
do I don't want to discount the fact
that women do like dick pics
we do the blue not out of the consensual
dick pic yeah if I asked for it or a lot
of girls like to get like if they're
just starting to talk to a guy he'll
send a video of them jacking off and a
girl will like that that's different but
that's because they're so do you think
we really don't like the visual part of
you're a true so there's actually you
know how there's love languages there's
like for emotional whatever there's also
like sexual I forgot what it's called
but it's in shans book a desire yeah and
that in that book I learned like there's
different ones like there's like a cat
and mouse like that's how if someone
could get turned on a specific you love
the chase or like being chased and
there's another one where like someone
could just show up naked like you open
the door to your bedroom and your man's
there standing naked and like looking
hot as [ __ ] and then you're like yes I'm
good let's go and then other people need
like an act like an acts of service kind
of thing we're like oh I I set up the
candles and like I did all that I did
the dishes okay like a romantic dishes
Nicky would get horny yeah yeah it's me
on so much ever since he learned that he
does the dishes all the time and you
come home from like a long day of work
yeah house is cleaning yeah they're
clean and you're like oh that's what can
go yes 100% that happens and still
happens oh my god well I just realized
we're hoping because we're like
this is how you get late yeah we're
telling you yeah you're late after
marriage
dude you know what guys should also for
me mine is okay I'm sure I have like
some kind of trigger thing but mine is
like really really hormonal like very
hormonal like the other day my guy and I
did something that like it wasn't the
act it was crazy it was how fast it
happened but it's because I was like in
the zone tree dies if you kind of know
like the weeks or you can sell like
signs like oscar-winner ovulation week
is actually went her period and then
just add a week yeah that's what she
even like the date just a day or so
after the period ends it's starting to
build yeah egg advantage of the week
after the period she's getting closer
you can last in there for a little bit
of time it's risky but that's why it's
hot dude for me like what really really
really gets me going it's like me
feeling like he wants it but man it's
like a really fine line because a creepy
zone like a knowing zone where it's like
okay chill so I feel for Casey sometimes
cuz I'm like damn man I can't help you I
don't know like there's like a thin line
you got a yeah it's like a tight rope so
yes but then it's like I don't know when
you get into this like mood of like
kissing me really passionately and like
he grabs me behind the head and like I
feel the fire that's when I'm like oh
I'm [ __ ] turned on and then there's
also like a sense of confidence to where
he's like you're my woman and I want you
right now and I'm gonna have you and
like that's that sets me off that's my
[ __ ] what takes you guys from completely
just not in the mood going about your
day to day you could even be kind of
just like uh - like what can a guy do to
actually make you interested physical
confident moves so like him opening his
whole hand
oh my thigh what I'm talking about is
the desire yeah and then I hire a mill I
can smell him and like it just it was
like spontaneous like that I like
spontaneity sometimes we have to plan
our spontaneity though like
have a window here's the window here's
the ladder and let's have a [ __ ] to
plan my own surprise party I'm like
listen my schedules pretty packed but I
like a surprise party so I could
surprise me on Friday your planner yeah
but what is it for you so let's say you
you know you have a good night with a
guy you're having drinks with him
everything's good let's say you go back
to the house and now you're on the couch
it's a leg out so what what is his first
move that makes you say like okay we
doing this we doing this we doing I mean
I think the classic like if we're on the
couch the pushing is [ __ ] dick up
against my butt cheese how did we get
caught at Point what do step before that
I don't know I just feel like he's hard
already
he's like blacks out the harm is
blacking out right now just thinking
about some [ __ ] and I can't put my
thoughts into words so wait start over
okay okay okay scenario you go on a date
with a guy it went okay on a scale of
one to ten it's like a god it's almost
like a five like you don't want to go
home but you're not feeling it too much
but you decide to just go back to his
place no I wouldn't I wouldn't for a fun
beach all right it's a save me like a
seven or eight no no it's it's not gonna
happen no but say you go back you're on
a six and you were just kind of like
feeling it out like you could go either
way at this point you could go home or
you could go okay big what does he do
that makes you say he would have to kiss
me and it would have to be a good kiss
like just going to kiss yeah it can't be
like timid I don't like the timid yeah
that's the biggest turnoff for me
because some women actually like that
but then there's there's there's a thing
we're like if it's like you have to be
skilled right so if you go in and you're
going on hardcore and but you're not
really skilled at it and you're just
like no other than like so it's just
it's hard to say like you have you just
have to be skilled and it's just
something that comes into time like how
would I understand what a skilled thing
is then if for the guys listening like
her but anybody learned
I mean correct don't perfect ask me can
I kiss you oh don't don't ask me that I
think open me to women I've told so it's
confusing messages well yeah if I'm on
the fence its stimulating conversation
that gets me to stay and then like you
know he's like hey one more drink so
then we like we pour our whisky on the
rocks and then we're like drinking our
whisky and we start talking about the
universe and then he's just like
watching you talk and then he stops
listening and then he interrupts you and
pulls your face into his yo oh yeah like
if he's stimulating me with that
conversation I'm like hole this guy
knows about black holes I'm trying to
think of a - TIFF what's yours you put
yourself in the same scenario as Jess
like what would be the like what's the
decided which day yeah I don't know with
my track record I would stay in a matter
no but okay but I really want to stay
yes no it really it really is that like
passion that I was talking about like
that that sense of making me feel like
protected and like he wants me but he's
like resisting but he really wants me
like I don't know like there's like this
desire even in a date you can feel that
energy it doesn't have to be that
obvious but yeah like I don't know just
feeling like with the kiss like what you
were talking about just like that's
really what set it off for me with like
me and Casey's first date like I said we
were like I said before we were at his
place and he was showing me movies or
whatever we get on the couch we put on a
movie and then as soon as like he he
like did the chin thing it's so [ __ ]
movie like it's so basic but he did the
chin thing where he like brought my chin
in closer to his face and then as he's
like started kissing me like I could
feel like the desire in that kiss and
that [ __ ] is what turned me on where I'm
like it's happening general first step
immunity the single finger cheek turn oh
and he played guitar you know it is
super like basic movie
steps and it were every girl is
completely different but and this is
like so this is why I'm like I'm not
advising guys to do this cuz every girl
is different but I like when a guy if I
already like a guy that's the key I
already have to like Tech's clues
general yeah yeah I have to already like
him and then he feels entitled to me I
like that [ __ ] so the first time that
Steve and I had sex he came inside me
without asking
Oh God and if that if that was no condom
no condom I wasn't control I was under
but like yeah he just been in a writing
I had known him for three years saying
not this is not why I advise but he
that's an [ __ ] thing to do well I
don't show got kids that is [ __ ] up
that's don't do that but because it was
him that did it I was like what a
[ __ ] [ __ ] then he kept going twice
I married that man he looks so goddamn
beta but that is some alpha action
big Spade already Wow there's a similar
thing I have it's near it's not nearly
as dangerous as when Nicki say like
don't do that but but my thing like so I
had sex with this guy and then after it
was over he like obviously you know if
you thought like time went by and he's
ready for round two but all he did was
he turned me on my stomach I still had
my underwear on
he just started jacking off like between
my budget and I was like this is weird
and I was like that's what it is like
that primal way that's like primal
instinct and over the like will
intellect I'm like like you're going for
what you want and you know what you can
get it yes son okay that makes me think
about okay when we were thinking about
our crushes last time I didn't say this
one cuz I was like I don't think any of
you guys will know who it is but I feel
like some people we're gonna know who
I'm talking about I am obsessed with
till linman from Ramstein and he's I
don't know the words yeah yeah yeah du
hast right up in this [ __ ] [ __ ] he's
like not like he's not look he's not
attractive and if you look he's like in
his like late 50s or so and he's just so
angry and I'm like I love it I love it
so so much and like there was a song I
was listening to the other day I don't
know why this okay can somebody explain
to me why this got me so much I'm
listening to it and this angry German
man I had to actually rewind because
there was like his voice went so low
that I was like my pregnant okay like
there's nobody has a good thing for like
just very like strong Angry Men yeah ya
know so Steve one month times he was
like yelling at somebody over the phone
about like one of his videos that didn't
get filmed properly or whatever and I
was like just the way like he was
confidently expressing his articulating
his points yeah angrily I was like you
I really he's not yelling he's just like
angrily articulating and I really like
it I could see it in you because you're
like he's just like like you went
somewhere we know is great are these
articulating them perfectly and the
other person doesn't have anything to
say again yeah you know what it's like
it's a challenge love I love me a strong
powerful man yeah and in like once
there's there's different ways that like
men can exude power and something of
silence yeah Oh power and silence
shooting silence every time oh they
don't gotta say [ __ ] they give you all
in family oh this guy would give me a
look just one look if I said something
kind of [ __ ] up and you'd just give me
a look and I would be like dude it's not
confidence to cut like I'm just thinking
about your masculinity yeah oh my god
little girl you know what it's because I
think okay hold on I'm just riffing here
and this is it for my first time diving
into this whole topic I think part of it
is because like I'm usually like kind of
like dominant and in control and I'm
like when I feel that coming off of a
man I'm like great you got this yeah I
don't have to do anything hands off I'm
gonna let Daddy Annie yeah yeah I feel
like I'm the similar way like in real
life and like non sex life I'm very like
control II like I like being in control
of everything but then when it comes to
sex if you take over that's the hottest
thing yeah I don't want to have to think
about anything and when it comes to sex
and feeling like I like not only are you
confident in what you're doing yeah like
everything you're doing is correct
you don't mean like like you're not
thinking about anything as in you're not
active or present in it I don't want
guys to think like oh they just want to
lay there no like I like so like I don't
want to have to take control take the
equation yeah exactly I want you to take
the wheel well you're talkative
participant well you can tell what is
turning me on and not turning me on and
I don't have to tell you anymore like we
already know each other like think of it
this way like
is being dominant and Nicki and I are
and more of a semester like submissive
role we're like your hype man
yeah we're yeah like we may not be doing
a lot of work but when you do something
we're like oh no yeah i yeah i'm giving
the worst advice on the show but when i
say no it means yes gary that's why
exactly it's already consensual okay
okay it's the way that i say no yeah
yeah Nicki she likes it because then
there are married Steve knows like he
knows the differences between the knows
if I'm like no I'm not in the mood
that's a note but if it's like oh no
like you're talking about a submissive
thing like that it's submission guys but
and I mean I mean you know I talk about
so often on the show how I'm usually
like dominant but like but I think I've
said before that I'm a switch yeah
you're a switch I I'm like I would say
like 75% dominant 25% dominant or 25%
submissive but if I'm going submissive
you have to earn that like you you you
gotta earn that but it's got to be that
thing we're like they are either like
really like home brooding and kind of
like angry and confident and I'm like
great I'll take that one over there like
sometimes I kind of want to piss off a
guy just so I have sex with me when he's
angry because I feel like it's a
different I feel like you do do that in
your relationship poke their buttons
until they get the complete opposite
like when when Kasey gets angry it gets
me angry I'm like why are you angry it's
cuz he gets angry over the silliest
things so I'm like that is just annoying
like not that kind of that's like
relationship issues even like early
early early days when we first started
dating like he was editing something and
then he just kind of like like he hit
his boiling point cuz the computer
wasn't working whatever he was not
having not having it and I was just kind
of there minding my own business like
working on my own stuff and then all of
a sudden he gets up he gets so angry he
has like this crazy like Hulk moment and
he punches a door he he creates all that
activity that's why it's not sexy that's
a bit you said [ __ ] yeah that's me
what if what we're looking for is all
right picture this you're a housewife
nobody in New York City
you're you've got your little apron on
and you're cooking and you're your
husband comes home and he slams the door
the stock markets crash here it's your
[ __ ] April from the recoup all the
money no problem but first he needs to
let off some steam oh let some Christian
great stuff she's a great stuff yeah
that is hot but yeah you're right like I
don't know every time he has like his
anger temper tantrum that was not a
manly I have never seen him be angry
like that there you go temper tantrums
yeah but I don't know that's why it's
for me I'm like that [ __ ] does not turn
me on it pisses me off
yeah j'en you come home from work okay
you actually made a stop at the mall and
you spent $15,000 at Chanel [ __ ] you put
the bags down on the table and your
husband looks at you and he's like you
[ __ ] [ __ ] my favorite because I win
both ways Wall Street rips your brain
meat juices I would not want this to be
ripped but because I love my third love
bra
so thanks third love for sponsoring this
so the reason why I love my third love
is because it fits perfectly so what I
did is I went online I took a quiz they
asked you like what kind of shapes your
breasts are and what like the shapes are
those - Oh mine are bell shape they're
beautiful no
um anyway so then they ask you like what
kind of current bra problems are you
experiencing right now like are the
straps too tight do you get that back
fat that pops out I hate that oh yeah or
do you have like extra like up like
spillage or whatever and gap that's what
it's called
the gap or you could get spillage of
your titties yeah they're too tight so
they actually help you out with the fit
finder quiz and they do give you the
perfect fit promise so every customer
has 60 days to wear it wash it and put
it to the test and if you don't love it
you have 60 days to return it so there's
comfort and quality which is hands-down
my most comfort comfortable my most
favorite bra that I own and also they
donate all of their gently used returned
bras to women in need so they support
charities in their local San Francisco
Bay Area and across the United States so
third love knows there's a perfect bra
for everyone so right now they are
offering our listeners 15% off your
first order go to third love comm slash
big mood now to find your perfect
fitting bra and get 15% off your first
purchase
that's third love comm slash big mood
for 15% off today and you know what else
is amazing
my favorite shampoo and conditioner from
function of B my two I've had mine for
almost eight months now that bottle
never runs out I love it it's the best I
love how customizable it is to where you
can you fill up that quiz and it's like
what are your hair goals do you want
more volume do you want more shine do
you want more structure what do you want
and then they customize it the formula
to that and then they also customize the
scent that you want and the color that
you want yes and they put your name on
the damn bottle yes I love mine I got
unscented because that is you I was okay
straight naturally processed hair
function of beauty individually for me
formulates every bottle based on your
unique hair type style preferences and
hair goals you just have to take a short
for question quick quiz also a function
of beauty is vegan and cruelty-free they
never use sulfates parabens phthalates
mineral oils or any other harmful
ingredients and we love
that to get started right now go to
function of beauty calm slash big mood
to take her for part hair profile quiz
and save 20% on your first order don't
spend another minute in hair misery go
to function of beauty calm slash big
mood to let them know that we sent you
and support the show that's function of
beauty calm slash big mood yeah question
for you guys feel like it's kind of a
typical one but what's your like what's
your touching hot spot like what what's
like there I feel like there's no guys
[ __ ] my neck okay my dude I was gonna
say like the thighs is the go spot for
me the neck is the we'll start here spot
for me like I like thighs under the
table at dinner when you're an agreeing
oh yeah it's like I'm gonna have you
later
I like the thigh but the thigh itself is
not enough I like when they kind of
[ __ ] like credit card iam little bit
now where they're like playing around
with it in public but la gonna do the
side thing and then just kind of like
got my clothes up there for me it's like
um there's this thing that case he
always does way he ends up like kind of
like smelling my neck oh yeah he kind of
like even smells yeah favorite spot of
my hole I mean big snows a cheater he
loves like this little like nook right
here is my spot right here he like goes
he's like he goes in he goes even like I
haven't showered like I've been wash and
I feel gross yeah like oh this is
wonderful animals nose my forehead
yeah he's eager to reach like Mickey
he's just trying to give you a forehead
my I think I'm you know what mine is
actually I think the the core spot like
for me is the but like just row yeah for
sure just rub my but because it can also
be so like non-sexual I mean like it
sounds like it is but like sometimes
guys are just appreciating their but
they're like yeah this is my woman yeah
and I'm like keep on rubbing that dick
I'm like make it round
it's so much that I don't even like
anymore you know he's constantly
touching your butt ever I really notice
anymore there's this one thing that guys
do that I love is like when they come up
behind you and they kind of grab your
like under your ribcage kind of on your
stomach yeah or like and then they'll
kind of like bring you in or I don't
know just being manhandled with around
the ribcage or below it like do doing
any motion a guy makes that basically
says you were my property we're all
gonna cancel is gonna send me over the
edge I am I am your guy does that says
you have no voting rights like when like
I get that because even like we'll be
walking in public and then he'll just
grab my hand like to hold hands but like
the fact that he grabs it on my kids
you're cute when he grabs my hand I mean
we're talking about like things that
just make me love know it shoots when he
sends me a kiss he blows me kisses oh my
god I would love that it's getting too
sentimental I don't like it I don't love
there's this thing that you just do that
always like makes me have butterflies
where he like looks at me and he goes
huh he does yeah every time he does like
he edited music to it I mean but it was
an unintentional edit which have cracked
me up even more it was like a hit on the
beat anyway but yeah it's like the
eyebrow thing you thought he does too I
like it oh I'm trying to think what does
something like really is there anything
like cute well Nicki said that hers
Steve doing the dishes was something
that's kind of like oh but like
looks-wise like when like there's
certain looks that Steve gives me that
is like it's like I know he's adoring me
you know where he is he looks at me and
he makes this face that's like like I
just love everything about you like that
does that turn you on
oh and we're just getting into love [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] oh you wanna get horny oh okay
I think fingers the [ __ ] out of my paw I
don't like think okay well kinda cute
thing that made me go right into
intercourse was my guy there was one
night and it was early on when we
started dating while completely like
shirtless like not totally naked just
shirtless there was a fly that got into
my room that was flying around and he
just like in one swift motion just
reached up I wrapped one fine and I was
like Karate Kid you fit it and he was
like he was like I think so and then in
his sexy shirtlessness walked outside of
my apartment to let the flag go like
humanitarian a little bit of man yes
squishes no he did it he let the fly go
get harder just yeah and then he came
back too soon and he just shut the door
and I was like you get on that bed right
now he washes my hands I started to
mention that but I felt like it went
without saying but I was I couldn't get
on that bed and I'm right that penis
until the Sun comes up
that that was like a sweet but I don't
get that story for some reason I mean
because I wasn't there but I just I just
thought like oh what's the alternative
to like if you had a flyswatter and he
just wanted the fly against the wall
guys thank you manatee really like the
sweet part of it but then also the
manliness of just like the skill of
grabbing the fly out of yes yeah what
are you afraid
it was so hot and I would like that with
some I really just really loved him that
was the moment that I was like I'm
marrying him it was it was that did it
for me it really was I can't picture
myself in that scenario being like oh
yeah with the flight and the first time
Steve and I had sex um we like we were
trying not to because the first couple
of times we tried like we were nerves
got the best of us and stuff and so we
were like okay he was about to go home
he had an early morning and we just
started showing each other our favorite
SNL sketches and I was like have you
seen this one just like oh yeah have you
seen this one and then we both were like
cracking each other up with there's our
favorite sketches and then we ended up
ripping each others clothes often so
laughter made you yeah basically shared
laughter I thought about that at first
cuz I was thinking okay what would make
me stay in a guy's house and you guys
know I love memes I love I love people I
love those meme collection dude I yes
literally like show me your love
language but the problem with that is is
I thought okay I like laughs and
exchanging laughs and my first instinct
just be like oh yeah show me your memes
on the TV and we would sit and laugh and
ha but I think I think that I'd be like
alright I'm gonna go home now yeah I
don't know if they're I swiped on a guy
online and then he started like texting
me memes and I was like to see you doing
it for me even though I love memes I
follow [ __ ] ton of meme accounts for me
that flirtation thing like dad it didn't
work it's just not deep all Ames are
funny when you discover them on your own
like I feel like just or like constantly
like pushing other people to like a meme
or to look at it it's not as funny it's
like the discovery of oh I'm just in
this coffee shop and then I see this
funny [ __ ] yeah it's not funny that just
thing was like oh we have the same sense
of humor yeah cuz we were cracking each
other up with our favorite sketches yeah
when you start to realize you have the
same sense of humor
somebody it actually really does elevate
something because you have something in
common yeah like there's no you're just
like yeah we laugh at that we it's like
maybe you have the same perspective on
life or the same like cynicism or
something like that but you catch on to
that very quickly and that's attractive
when somebody has some so have you like
known somebody that thinks something
that's really not fun
you're just like yeah
horrible comedy who also Competitiveness
if they can hold their own and like we
get into like a competition about
something I really like that I get
really turned on for that you know it's
a random-ass thing too that really turns
me on is is stick shift just driving
with the stick shift I don't know to me
I like it - that's really [ __ ] hot a
stick shift so every time I see him like
yeah he does he joins up VW sticks yeah
he has a Jetta no all his cars he's
always like the the manual so but yeah
and just seeing him I'm just like and I
remember it when we first started dating
- I put my hand over his as he was like
shifting gears I'm like this is so hot
all right I think it's also stick is
usually something that like men do so
it's a little bit of masculinity but I
think it also ties back into that thing
we were talking about with like having a
talent or a skill it's like when when I
when a guy can do something good like we
can't really do or that we wish we could
do or something like that we immediately
get a little bit of respect for them and
respect is kind of hot yeah like it
definitely is like I can't date somebody
if I don't respect yeah we have to have
respect so you can disrespect me yeah so
so I give it to you and then you take it
away yeah because if you get
disrespected by someone you don't
respect yes like oh yeah I will beat
your ass right now I would say the word
I'm put my underwear back on but I don't
like to be I really don't like to be
disrespected but I do like to be
disrespected but I do like to be
humiliated absolutely well you were
beause you were talking before about
like how when a guy puts his arm behind
his his his head that's like really sexy
and turns you on immediately oh yeah
yeah legal cues yeah yeah this is really
confident and I actually
I was talking to a friend of mine she's
a female and generally she was telling
me when she goes into negotiation she
does this like she puts her arms she
puts her hands behind her head yeah she
puts her hands behind her head because
she said to the power man well it's kind
of a Power Move because she's spreading
herself out but she's also saying like
I'm open everything I'm saying to you is
completely honest like it's true like
I'm not hiding anything I'm not closed
off but it's just also a very language
of dominant stance you know leaning back
that confidence of like like I'm not I'm
not a web position yeah it's like I'm
not like on edge I don't need to lean in
and try to pretend to assert myself you
know it's just like I'm very confident
and hot yeah I I mean I like that
there's no positions that like a guy
like puts himself in or like you see
something and you're like oh amazing mmm
- be when I was 16 when I could see a
little bit of the boxers oh yeah I had I
just had a flash if a guy is wearing a
suit and he comes home and he takes the
tie off and just like it's like the
equivalent of taking her bra oh yeah
where he takes the tie off and I'm buds
a thing and he's like sorry Jess what
was that motion was this a clip one with
one hand not with one hands you put in
my head with so much and then he does
his homework no no no but I give us you
me my picture just [ __ ] evaporate I
get what you mean got guy coming home
with it picture this it's New York Stock
monkey just crazy
drops his suitcase on the floor does it
clean it up no oh dude the other day um
I I asked Steve to come upstairs to help
me clean and I was in a full-on french
maid lingerie
oh yeah so sexy was that he hustled up
the stairs to help me clean cuz he
didn't know not that I needed help
cleaning and he was like yeah whatever
you need and like he came up the stairs
and he's like oh [ __ ]
but he the fact that he wanted to help
me clean was like oh this mamaia this
work did you guys what happened that
like never do that I never have lingerie
I never surprised him with lingerie but
I was trying to find this like sexy pair
of black underwear that he likes cuz
like to let him know that I'm want sex
and I found this french maid lingerie
outfit that someone had given to me on
my bachelorette party and I was still
the packaging and I was like I wonder if
this fits because I had just recently
lost weight and I was like I haven't
been confident enough to wear lingerie
in years so I I went to try it on and I
was like oh [ __ ] I was like honey can I
clean like it's like really messy here
and he comes up the stairs like right
away oh my god hey good right because I
would have been like give me an hour
[ __ ] okay and then but he knows my love
language is acts of service so yeah and
I'm like yeah it's over here and he
comes around the corner and he's like oh
my god oh wow he goes well immediately
his eyes get was like wow well and he
just starts reaching for my ass like
just immediately yeah you're so hard
well I can't no but then he puts me he
like he ripped yeah yeah he's like he's
like get on your knees like yeah oh yes
sir did you get a bonus pay for that I
got a boner pay for that I'm gonna try
that now I want to try a little I want
to try a little role play I surprising
him out of nowhere yeah really I did
that recently oh oh so you both yeah so
I recently got it Valentine's Day
lingerie and we hadn't tried it yet so
with the move and everything so I put it
on
and because he was taking a shower did
he pick it out yeah he gave it okay yeah
and so he was in the shower while I was
putting it on but then I put my regular
PJ's over it the lingerie and then so he
gets out of the shower and I'm like I
have a surprise for oh because he
started kissing me and I like I'm like I
have a surprise for you I'm like close
your eyes and so he closes eyes and then
I take off my PJ's really quick and then
you could see the whole laundry he's
like oh my god I'm like it's right know
but I had never surprised him like that
before so that was yeah new things in
marriages like after you've been with
someone for a long time like trying
something new for the first time is so
fun yeah and it really Valentine's Day I
got him some like restraints howdy okay
I always wondered like how does that go
down like do you just like wait there
while he ties it and you're like okay oh
he pins me down it like I can't move no
I mean not just that how do you give me
it I'm like with my legs I'm still like
trying to like touch and like do things
with my legs mm-hmm so I'm still active
I'm Charlotte no one's ever tied me -
yeah you're like the romantic sex life
that's me yeah no oh no one time one
time this guy handcuffed me to a towel
rack Lucinda come on I feel like it's so
flimsy tolerate this is really
embarrassing a jug deal that went wrong
I really like this guy at a time like I
loved cooking and like that was like my
main passion was just like cooking and I
told him that I could make the best
steak ever and I went out and bought
these really fancy steaks and I burnt
the steak wait how do you burn it well I
mean he liked a rare to medium-rare
steak and I cooked that [ __ ] well-done
and he took a bite and he was like all
right let's get to the next part and
then next thing you know I was
handcuffed to the table wait wait what
was that bathroom because I was at a
spot where I
really liked him and I was kind of down
to do whatever he's like let's talk
about the steak get in the bathroom oh
my god this whole scene is very what he
wanted to do in the bathroom I mean I do
it I was in the like hold phase of leg
I'm 20 and I just want guys to like me
and so like yeah I don't know how we
ended up in the bathroom I'm not judging
people's kinks I just wanted to know is
this trauma no no it was I I enjoyed it
okay I did I did enjoy that I feel at
least move into like a sexy shower oh no
no no no it started in the bedroom it's
started in the bedroom I do not remember
how we ended up in there but all I know
is like there was a bar that was for
towels and I was handcuffed okay so also
what's the dismount of being tied up
you're just like everybody came and
you're like okay that was so long ago
eight years ago this happens when you
[ __ ] a tumblr guy okay oh my god yeah
like dude tumblr went through a period
where like everyone was just posting a
bunch of sex stuff so like everyone's
fantasies were like at just an
unrealistic vision Nikki looks scared
I've ever been on tumblr very dominant
he was he was super super dominant and
like I remember I had such a crush on
him because he was he was like six foot
two and he was like really into the
hardcore scene and I remember my
favorite picture of him was a picture of
him with a black eye from after he got
out of like a mosh pit and so I was like
yeah you can handcuff me to anything
yeah and I'm like yeah I'll make you a
steak and potatoes you man you yeah you
[ __ ] man and then the tables turn and
then I started beating men but like my
insult yes with their consent yeah it's
always a sensual like what their pleads
so yeah I I just like I think for me
like my overall like just I just need a
band that is just very like in control
and acts like really really confident
powerful like that is my number one that
is my number one trigger yeah number one
if they're gonna do that though they got
a smell nice oh yeah oh absolutely I'd
love a little Cologne on a man but if
he's not gonna wear cologne how about a
little deodorant yes that's right
how about native if you're worried about
what you're putting on your body in your
deodorant this is aluminum free paraben
free talc free also vegan and never
tested on animals get a sniff sniff of
that as well every single ingredient
that you're gonna read on this you'll
probably know and it actually works I'm
a person that's 11 during roses can wear
this this is good yeah yeah I could I
could follow so many armpit yeah a
little bit of male pheromones and some
sweat there little pheromones
man that's the man the one yeah they've
ladies and men though oh here it is I
want to wear this one sea salt and cedar
everyone this is this is nice see salt
and cedar yes amazing sense something
for everyone and there's absolutely no
risk to try you get free shipping on
every order and 30 days for free returns
or exchanges in the USA also not to
mention the product has over 9,000
five-star reviews that's okay that's the
same people really out here because you
know people don't always be reviewing
stuff people going out of their way to
review this and had a lot of people
didn't love it anymore beauty first 20%
off your first purchase visit native
deodorant and use the promo code big
mood during checkout again for 20% off
of your first order
use the code big mood at checkout visit
native deodorant dot-com and what I
really need deodorant is after I've been
working now and I like to work out with
Noom which is an app that it not only
helps you with your working out schedule
your exercise regimen but also just the
psychology behind that behind the
choices you make so eating better to
feel better rather than eating to fill a
void in your soul yeah also like if you
have social
xiety is a lot of times for me like at
prom I would cling to the dessert table
and I just be scarfing those
strawberries cover strawberries you
don't even realize it but you're just
after yeah because that anxiety takes
over so it's about building habits in
more ways than one both mentally and
physically
it's based on psychology new teaches you
why you do the things you do and
empowers you with the tools to break the
bad habits and replace them with better
ones everyone is busy that's why Newman
doesn't demand much of your time they
only ask for 10 minutes a day who
doesn't have 10 minutes a day it's based
on cognitive behavioral approach and
uses personalized courses to help you
reach your specific goals and you're
assigned to a goal specialist so just
matched up with the community of numers
so there's always support and people
going through the same things that you
are so it's a perfect time to make a
step towards healthier habits sign up
for your trial today
NUMA comm slash big mood that's n oom
comm slash big mood what do you have to
lose visit new mom / big mood to start
your trial today that's Noom and oh oh
em calm / big mood horny horny what do I
do
well anyone's anyone's labial fools
getting swollen and we're back in five
labia folds okay I'll sing it when I was
thinking about how he said like sixteen
year old brains wanted oh we just want
your boxers to be showing a little bit
and like now I'm like absolutely no I
really wanted spiked hair oh really I
did but you know what I had I think for
Tolos for a little bit oh I think that
that was Mike's hair ago and then maybe
even also lysine the choice was kind of
like habitat for the cholos person was
hip relabelled head I'm like yeah like
they were hip with the rioters I had my
face with skaters you know sublimes a
music video wrong way
there's a skater guy in there he was my
exact type yeah I'm
can you show me that yes daemul song for
me personifies like a sixteen year old
girl getting horny off of [ __ ] that's
where I learned the word horny yeah cuz
they say horny and that song and I asked
my dad I was like in fifth grade I was
like horny Mike that was the first time
I heard that song too in wrong way
actually that's really funny for the
word [ __ ] mmm Oh cuz he owes I was
reading from the pamphlet like the
lyrics off the Panther all the day and I
thought it said war and I was like why
did he say [ __ ] my type was bleached
blond tips yes tip oh my god I think it
was Mark yes or what say yes mark mark
McGrath oh there's a baseball player and
there's mine was also the Leonardo
DiCaprio hey the like little swoopy is
always did it with red Pitt have that in
white clothes oh yeah
what is the 2020 equivalent of the
haircut that all the guys all the guys
have that like bleached blond like bull
mushroom haircut now dude the ramen hair
I was obsessed with just not like the
hair but that Justin Timberlake was like
when I first discovered that I never
liked him because of his hair I couldn't
get over the ramen hair I was Nick
Carter fan so I felt like I had to
choose between Nick Carter or Justin
Timberlake I was a Slim Shady fan you
know what else I remember like being if
we're talking about being our teenage
selves like if you're with a guy and you
guys are like sharing music with each
other and it's like oh the same
headphone it's like one o'clock in the
morning and you're like oh listen to
this song and you're like oh this song
is really cool I like this song sharing
SNL sketches oh what I'm wondering what
my what my thing is gonna be okay
wait we just ran through what it was in
our teens what is it what was it for
late 20s like not for mine it was
suddenly like a flip swish of oh my god
you have your own place and you pay
bills
let it go you know get this term fired
we're tired but guess which mine was you
having your own place and paying bills
like that is my twenties mine was like
the sound of a [ __ ] bottle cap coming
off a liquor bar Martin Jesse's like
mine was when you packed the cigarette
on the bottom of your living in New York
all the time she's like when you can pay
bills in New York
Wall Street style is crashing and you
still pays the bill all of my address is
like he's flipping up a Budweiser
trailer we will never know I have a lot
of experience with not big things in
Texas wait wait what is y'all's what was
y'all's late twenties thing well I was I
mean I got married at 27 yeah but what
were you looking at Casey I don't know
I'm like dude I'm like a serial
monogamous I'm Way too loyal for my own
good it's like once I'm locked in like I
I don't really look at it go with the
going with the river that's why I like
celebrities I'm like that's the closest
and even you know how we did our last
episode we were talking about hot
celebrities it was hard for me to like
really look into you just what your
answer was just Jason Momoa all right
no and Joseph gordon-levitt Oh young
Brad Pitt oh yeah yeah Todd I'm so mad
because all of them would [ __ ] if
right now well I'm betting they were
like this is always coming from our
perspective of like for you think that
but say they're like they have access to
literally every woman I don't know like
what would make a celebrity you try to
say that they wouldn't [ __ ] if Jess
that say like they have access to
literally every woman in the world so
why would they that's why they would go
for a basic baby hello hey you bet your
ass me like why would you go for a girl
like me
I don't want to be this out cut me out
of this just don't want any rights Jess
well yeah I don't know like for me like
I don't know like you just I don't know
I suck at this okay yeah well my thing
was this and I'll stuff in my late 20s
that's when that's when Steve and I
first started dating and that was the
end of my whole face like when we
started like oh I actually like you as a
person let's go let's go have some
humour you know okay I know sorry I
interrupted you got it something like a
light bulb flip switch like like an
adventure guy that's like adrenaline
like I divert that I had rides a
motorcycle and I'm looking goes like
Robbie marry that I did not but my late
20s I was looking at guys like that
where I'm like oh I'm actually not an
operative I don't like all the
adrenaline I'd rather have good at
Google then good at skydiving I want
them to like know how to keep the stock
market from crashing yeah right actions
of mountains know cuz like those guys
they also tend to be like the handier
guys in like a handyman looking hot I
also feel like they're always like
escapism people though they like would
rather live in the wild or like in a
bunker somewhere I'm like I'm just not
down yeah well that's like two extremely
yeah for me it's like just like some
manly man okay motorcycle man what I
mean it's either that or the complete
opposite so I'm both at both ends yeah
mine's more way more nerdy I didn't be
nerdy nerd it out yeah is if you if you
are going to date me and we are entering
into a relationship agreement getting
serious this is getting really illegal I
mean it's just a relationship agreement
I need you to live and I cannot have you
falling out of the sky
driving fast well that's why you got to
get on that life insurance you got a
lock them down gotta give them a life
insurance plan then you but hey ghosts
I I need I need so yeah when my guy and
I first started dating when we very
first started dating he said he wanted a
motorcycle and I said great you do that
thank you for this date the food was
wonderful and I really liked you he was
probably just trying to sound cool he
was like no no no I don't need this yeah
yeah I know I don't need it it's fine
let's not have that motorcycle and now
he talked about some fast car get a Ford
car I can't take it it's like you know
it will make it to a point in in
relationships we're almost like like I
hate to draw this comparison but I mean
like we're almost like moms to an extent
where we're like I need you to live like
you're my baby
well then biologically be like you want
them to protect the family like yeah
it's like primitively what's wrong with
me then what do you mean because I want
that you like I want like I forced Casey
you're just born like a spice I got my
motorcycle license and I'm like can you
get yours too so we carry bags together
because I don't want you being in the
backseat holding on yeah my ex had a
motorcycle only a motorcycle no car so
like if I if he was driving like I had
to hang on and we almost crashed when I
was a scariest thing in my life and
since then I'm like no motorcycles you
cannot have them yeah I don't know what
I for some reason I'm just not turned on
by the motorcycle guy no as soon as I
find out they have one or they like
riding bikes I'm like oh yeah well also
and I told you guys about that
motorcycle guy that I went on a date
with the hit a car and I got a
third-degree burn [ __ ] yeah so no we
don't do realities not sexy I'm working
on it working on your motorcycle what a
[ __ ] loser that's a hot issue
I'm not into it I'm standing my ground
on it that's why I think that's why I
take some ammo is so attractive to me
because he does [ __ ] like he's so rugged
and like I don't know yeah but also so
loving and tender like he [ __ ] at the
scrunchie like poses risk he wears that
scrunchie proudly are like I feel like
when I see him with his wife I'm like oh
he's got a soft side they get their
hands to wash dishes when I was maybe
like 15 or so I had a friend who he was
like one of my best friends who happened
to have a hot brother his brother was I
thought his brother was so hot in
retrospect he smelled kind of funny but
one time he and he would never fought
back with me and I think it's cuz I was
like a year or two younger I think he
was a junior and I was a freshman and so
he would never flirt back with me until
one day he got a motorcycle and pretty
sure this guy had been held back for a
year or something he got a motorcycle
and he offered to let me go out on a
ride with him and obviously I'm gonna
say yes cuz I'm like finally this is my
chance to lock him in like I'm ready for
this [ __ ] I was on the back of [ __ ]
an interstate 101 wait he's like hold on
to me babe Casey holding on his crying
I've known you know why I like the
motorcycle thing is so like just I don't
know it's huge for me is because my very
first crush when I was like seven years
old or eight years old it was this guy
he was a family friend
so I mean till this day I still interact
with him he's kind of like my uncle but
when I was little really little before I
knew better I was like obsessed with him
and he had this motorcycle he would
always do wheelies on the street like in
front of us and I'm gonna rock it my
first credit is my motorcycle what no my
first crush was Michael J Fox which
Michael J Fox back to my future Michael
J Fox okay the three yeah those six
Kancil we already got cancelled so now
one even made it this far
yeah damned my y'all are still making
fun of me for Jimmy Fallon yeah my
second crush Jaleel White in Family
Matters when he was uncle not when he
was the fun I did not like it he changed
wait the worst choice Nicky at five like
purple eyes law had dreams about him
that was my first dream kiss ever thank
you guys for watching this week I think
ovulation has ended personally in the
Venera the end of an era the end of an
ovulating era but guys thank you so much
for watching thank you for coming back
weeks week by now our youtube series I'm
assuming has come out let us know if you
like that stuff tweet us your favorite
moments will drop your wheat or retweet
and like tell us in the comments what
else do you want to hear from us what do
you want what are you missing shoe it
turned on by yeah what do you I want to
judge what gets your pickle going what
gets your vessel leaking the wall I just
orifice yeah what's your get your or
radiating Wiccans right goodnight we'll
see you next week make sure you leave us
five stars on on [ __ ] Apple podcast
your Apple podcast come back see us next
week shares with the girls the boys
everybody we'll see you soon play